today's topic now look I had no
intentions of covering with Justin
Timberlake scandal because I don't
really care Daniel whatever he
apologized to his wife or if you aren't
aware Justin Timberlake we're shooting a
movie and at what point he was out on
some balcony New Orleans with his
co-star and they were getting a little
frisky or something and someone caught
some tapes of it and internet went crazy
I don't care
but vais came out with this article and
basically they said it was Justin
Timberlake's fault that his co-star came
on to him now here's the thing the
articles from Vice so I should have
stopped right there yes because vice has
lost all his journalistic credibility a
long time ago what happened he's
arguably better understood as a
workplace issue one that involves a
powerful man getting drunk and
physically inappropriate with a younger
less powerful female colleague the
problem isn't that Justin Timberlake is
married instead he got drunk and started
pawing at his co-star potentially
forcing her to navigate a tricky
situation she probably didn't sign up
for when she signed on for the film I
hate this idea that because a woman has
less power within some kind of structure
that she has no agency
she has no responsibility for her
actions that any involvement that she
has with someone who has more perceived
power somehow means that she's incapable
of being punished for whatever mistakes
that she makes that's what kills me I
know this article's ridiculous but there
is this general belief in the world that
a superior can never be physically
involved with someone who's below them
and I think it's generally a bad idea to
do so because of the fact that society
is that way but to me it's completely
backwards that women are being told you
have your rights you have your
responsibilities do your thing but as
soon as it gets the workplace you know
you're a feeble person you don't you
don't have ins you didn't have the right
makeup mental makeup to handle
relationship with someone who's older
she was taking advantage of you that is
the immediate assumption so while I do
tell men in positions of power
never
with someone below them especially not
in their workplace and I'm not talking
about moms who like to be like if you
want a promotion you've got to do this
or if you need to that's not what I'm
talking about that's not even implied
stuff I'm not talking about that I'm
talking about the simple fact that the
Secretary may want her boss and it's a
very plausible thing and here's the
worst part if we know that 40% of
relationships and 40% of intimate
relationships happen and I start in the
workplace wouldn't it make sense that
women would desire the man who is the
boss no no no no I mean we just had
another video before we didn't want to
make out yeah they want to make them
down they don't want to date down you
don't want to don't want to dig down
deep you don't want to date down right
it wouldn't be possible right I'm just
saying you you don't want to date down
so I'm like maybe you want to date up no
no if they beat up it's because they're
feeble and and the end he was
manipulating her I'm confused
rough there's nothing to say I'm just
gonna stare into the camera it's like yo
dudes just can't win even if she starts
it we influenced her if a man and a
woman is drunk he takes advantage of her
because a man has more power and more
responsibility how is that equal it's
convenient what is it's convenient that
she's people they feeble when they what
is convenient
you can't talk about yeah we don't need
no Prince and then you do all of a
sudden you're a glad yeah he charmed me
this is why I tell men do not even if
she says yes even if she's consensual
consent doesn't mean anything when you
have more power because in this society
you're still trash yeah so don't don't
do only engage don't do it of course I
women always say Oh women always say
it's in your head guys you guys are just
exaggerating these problems are not real
things listen don't listen to them if
you want to keep your job if you want to
be successful if you feel don't throw
away your career because someone lobbed
you an e-zpass for some poom poom don't
do it
okay if you take that poom poom your
career goes boom boom boom boom boom
boom I want you I'm gonna give it to you
you're gonna give it back to me imma sue
you through to you thank you
so anyways leave your comments below you
wanna know I apologized fur to my
amazing wife and family for putting them
through such an embarrassing situation
justin timberlake wrote i should have
known better
first thing Justin Thrun apologize to
your wife apologize to your wife not
through social media it's your wife
you're with her that's really just a
move for other people don't know the
business to let other people know daddy
apologize because if you really want to
apologize to your wife you apologize to
your wife nobody else have to know why
can't you do both why can't you do both
yeah of course you could do both but
it's just it's done in the desert that's
all I'm saying
keep your [ __ ] to yourself that is
really just damage control it just
smells like damage control but some
might argue because it's happening on
social media you should apologize on
social media nah they don't have to know
[ __ ] who you married to social media nah
it's like you don't when when there was
something going on with Jada Pinkett
it's me and Will Smith back then I mean
they kept it with them they kept it with
them
that's after life 15 years after when
they had like the red tabletalk and they
talked about it but other than that when
it happened if there was some apologies
we didn't hear about it because it's not
our goddamn business
so I'm saying
[Music]
whose hand is that yeah okay let me just
give you a pro tip okay hand on the
inside of the thigh that's letting a man
know business is going down when you
move from the outside to inside
there's no dilly-dally I don't care if
she's your sister she's trying to better
bring main main main main main man yeah
we're making a big deal out of something
that's not a big deal